now you might know we've been following
the course of this disease looking at
the data points over the course of the
last few months and I was desperately
hoping there was going to be some good
news to bring you right now about the
figures for the UK but I'm probably not
quite there yet it's mostly I'm afraid
yet more depressing news but there is
one piece of good news which is that we
are getting there when it comes to
excess deaths which is the key metric
we've been looking at over the course of
the last few weeks giving you a sense of
just how the UK is coping how this is
going in terms of Public Health how it's
going in terms of all of our lives our
family's excess deaths is that key
measure because it gives you a sense of
looking at the average number of people
who have died in recent years so you can
see this is the average who've died
starting in January and then going
through to where we are at the moment in
previous years and you can see it kind
of peaked in January and kind of flu
season but let's add on the line for
2020 there you can see pretty vividly
what happened with covet 19 so the
crisis increased the number of people
dying across the UK and I should say
this is dying death from all causes but
I'll show you covert 19 in a moment and
we were really hoping you know all of us
hope against hope that by now that black
line there would have got down to meet
the blue line so basically you'd have
had a moment where we weren't having any
excess deaths and many other countries
they are down at that moment right now
but I'm afraid we do still have 1800
people more dying more than average on
average due around this time of year
that's in the last week of May towards
the end of May and the depressing thing
really is when you add up the number of
people who have died above the average
over the course of this period so
basically the gap between the black line
and the blue line there you're talking
about 64,000 now so that's confirmed
deaths above the average that we've had
so far
of which 50,000 have been put down to a
covert 19 now those those are deaths
where they have Kovach 19 on the death
certificate but of course that still
leaves an extra 14,000 which are just
unaccounted for at the moment now the
only nurse the Office for National
Statistics thinks that might be covert
19 that was just undiagnosed it might be
other causes
like the lockdown and a lot of that is
happening in care homes at the moment
it's just difficult to get those deaths
certified in the way that they would
normally be and that's really kind of
about borne out by what we see here
which is looking at different deaths in
different settings and what you can see
the line here they're kind of bottom of
this is just zero access death so that's
the normal the average number of people
who died in these different settings
each year and this is the number people
who have died at home so in domestic
settings actually again above the
average and we we've talked a lot about
caring so we haven't talked as much
about deaths in domestic settings but
they're a lot higher than they normally
are at the moment and the fewer of them
are actually explained by Cove at 19
right now then you've got deaths in
hospitals so peaking early but then
coming down quite sharply and you can
see over there there are fewer people
dying in hospitals now or at least in
the latest week than usually do so fewer
people dying in hospitals right now than
then usually do negative excess deaths
as if you want to put it like that and
then you have care homes now this of
course of many many tragedies in this
epidemic is perhaps the greatest you can
see how the disease Peaks and then is
transferred from hospitals to care homes
and you have the greatest number of
deaths in care homes excess deaths in
care homes and also we're not there yet
again you've got more people dying in
care homes and at home than normally do
around this time of year so it is
certainly coming down but it's not there
quite yet and there has been lots of
talk over the course of the last week or
so about how the UK has well I saw one
story about her saying how the UK had
more deaths than all of Europe combined
well there's lots of depressing stuff
here but I wouldn't get too depressed by
that because there's a reason that we're
getting some statistics that make the UK
look particularly bad and it's because
of the nature of this line now this is
just covert 19 deaths that the official
count we get each day from the
government's and you'll probably notice
when you look at it it's a very jagged
line indeed what's happening here is
you're seeing lots of weekends here so
numbers kind of go down off the weekend
then they bounce back and you're seeing
the government also trying to fill in
the picture from previous weeks so
we didn't have a very good picture of
how many people were dying initially and
they're starting to fill that in the
real picture that we know now looks more
like this so this is by the way I should
say it's England and Wales it's just a
nice comparable numbers I've been able
to find but this is really what happened
this is what we now know when people
died from covert 19 over this period you
can see the line is a lot smoother and
also it was higher earlier so more
people dying early on in the pandemic
than we were them was reported by the
government at the time but right now
here's the key thing that line the white
line tends to be a bit lower than the
line we're getting a lot of the days
from the government so you might see
some scary numbers from the government's
about you know three four hundred people
perhaps dying in reality what's
happening is they're filling in the gaps
and trying to allocate some of those
deaths that they've only just kind of
found out I've only been registered on
two recent days the UK doesn't have more
deaths happening each day than all of
Europe combined but it certainly does
have one of the rest four worst records
for this disease of any country around
the world the best way of measuring that
is actually not looking at this but is
looking at excess deaths comparing it to
the size of the population and here's
the picture you're left with these
numbers some of them are from the FT
I've updated the UK with the latest data
we've just had through but what you can
see here is in terms of you know that
compared with the size of the population
number of excess deaths in the UK is
more than Spain Italy Belgium
Netherlands France US and Germany now
these figures getting updated all the
time so this is not definitive this is
not the last word on this but it does
just show you that the UK has one of the
worst crises in the world if not the
worst and well there it is it's a
testament to what we are going through
right now and if you kind of break up
the different parts of the UK what you
see is an interesting pattern so England
they're at the top so the worst outbreak
in the developed world in England
Scotland though also very high indeed as
well and that's perhaps slightly
underappreciated how many excess deaths
there have been in Scotland as a
percentage of the population then you've
got wells a bit further down and then
Northern Ireland really in a way as the
outlier with the least bad outbreak of
any part in the of the UK but it's worth
saying still worse than France or indeed
the US or Germany as per had
of the population now when we're looking
at these numbers
it's also worth just kind of looking at
a different way of measuring the number
of people who are dying of Kove at 19
and that's looking at trajectories so
not looking at the total cumulative
number of people who have died but
looking at kind of where we are heading
and this line shows you how many people
have died each day is a seven-day
average though in the UK and so it's a
similar picture up very sharply
initially in the crisis and then
gradually coming down I just sets a
logarithmic chart so it's kind of gives
you a representation of growth here but
if we compare that to other countries
we'll have a look at this I've picked
out a couple in particular here you can
see Brazil there and you can see Sweden
and actually the UK now if you just look
at the rate at which people are dying
each day the UK actually is below Brazil
and below Sweden at the moment and in a
way this underlines what we're seeing
right now with with covet 19 many
countries around the world are seeing
their numbers starting to fall at the
moment many in the developed world
whereas it's other countries like Brazil
to some extent India as well who is
seeing deaths increase quite sharply
right now I'll add on the US and Italy
in France so you can see that so in many
countries in the West it's coming down
in other countries in the emerging and
developing world it is starting to go up
that's where the disease is most rife
most intense at the moment in the UK
though as I say it is getting better I
know a lot of these numbers are very
depressing I know it's certainly looking
back at those totals it is deeply
depressing but we don't yet have any
evidence there is a second wave a lot of
people talking about the risk of a
second wave we're not there yet how look
at this this this is the key number
we're going to be looking at this is not
not deaths but cases so the number of
new cases in the UK now initially
testing was appalling so this didn't
give us a very good metric of what was
going on but we're gonna keep a close
eye on this and particularly where it is
right now so the number of new cases now
in the UK down to the lowest level it's
been since early on in this pandemic not
going up there isn't yet a sign of a
second wave so that is something to be
moderately reassured by and we're going
to keep a close eye on that over the
course
over the next few weeks and months to
you know get a sense of whether we are
indeed heading for another outbreak but
for the time being yes there are lots of
depressing news but happily a little bit
of slightly more reassuring news to